okay so as a buddha
here aikido uses
the catalyst of martial authenticity
to reconcile and to teach you
the skill of reconciling that ego
tripartite
okay
nevertheless i think you should have
some sense of self-defense
in your training
and therefore not make the mistake that
a
relatively few
techniques that people after the founder
came
[Music]
and made a curriculum from and called
that aikido you should not make the
mistake that that
limited curriculum is going to do
or meet a self-defense need you
have to fill in the gap okay
so this is uh a drill on
in fighting kicking okay
the infinite kicking may be
something you use but it at the minimum
it's something that's
looming so a guy cannot just
stand there and play with my collar
or my neck while they decide
what to do they have to press
because if they don't they have
infighting kicking to deal with just
like they would have infighting elbows
and infighting
hand strikes okay so there's three of
them
that we're doing now
and they're going to help meet that
in-fighting self-defense situation where
they're tactically looming or they're
being tactically deployed
they don't have to be deployed in this
order in fact i would
imagine they wouldn't be this is just a
drill and as
a drill it's working on the coordination
that many aikidoka don't have because
you just have a curriculum made up of
very limited
movements okay but to do those movements
correctly i'm supposed to have an
athletic coordination
so i find this interesting for those two
reasons
self-defense and let's improve our
athletic coordination
okay so this drill doesn't really work
on a bag because the nature of the kicks
although we can do a knee kick
on a bag uh but the next two kicks they
don't work so well on the back so
he's not really fighting me he's just a
target so keep your feet out of the way
so your toenails and stuff don't get
ripped
i pulled my strikes but i don't pull all
of them
because it's good for him to feel some
contact and it's good for me to have
some contact okay
so the first one is going to be a knee
kick
heel hook scoop kick combination so
i'm here boom knee kick turn
heel hook scoot again
one two three
okay that's our drill go and then uh
you're just a target
uh there's energy so here i have forward
energy into the knee thrust so i use
that to come
in when i hit i use that energy to
rotate
boom and when it hits down i use the
rebound to help turn me
so i'm transferring energy just like
when i do a
you throw me i transfer the energy into
the forward roll
so i'm not letting energy stop
and a new movement and then a new
movement everything is going
and i'm just bouncing back and forth off
each kid
so through i'm out
trying to transfer the energy okay